hi I'm Emily Levine terribly sorry to
announce that I'm replacing Danny Hillis
who has a sinus condition that didn't
allow him to fly today and the only time
I've ever had a more intimidating
circumstance was replacing gore Vidal at
the last moment so hi nice to meet you
I'm actually really nervous because I
looked at your bio about 20 minutes
before I came out here and you're a
comedian yes I am I'm scared of
comedians well you know I I have to say
you were on The Colbert show and I
looked at that and you were wearing the
same socks haven't haven't washed them
either I'm trying to save energy
I couldn't decide whether you had a
hundred pairs of the same socks or just
never watched them my wife will love you
so if she actually bought me not a
hundred but ten pairs of these socks
well I like them that's why I noticed
something but and she loves everyone is
fascinated by this Danny Hillis type
conversation so actually you're speaking
of Stephen Colbert was was fascinating I
was like don't try and be funnier than a
comedian because they'll kick your ass
but the truth is you know I'm gonna say
something personal and I'm please don't
I I don't mean this is I also watched
your TED talk okay and it seemed to me
because I'm a performer and I look at
things like breathing and voice quality
and stuff it looked at me as if you were
more nervous on your TED talk and then
completely not nervous on Colbert you
you age and you get wisdom aha
I suspect and you just surrender but Ted
is a very strange format and then they
they actually they're they're even more
fascist with the Bell and the buzzer
then you know then I did it three times
but I did it before the whole focus
switched over to TED talks where you
really had to be on time you had to be
rehearsed you had to wear makeup so
anyway um Danny did want me to express
his admiration for you as I will express
my admiration for Danny okay this is
what I love just being the middle person
here
but also he did want me to ask you about
why you don't think fusion will hear
everything but you've already sort of
said it won't and 9 let's not go into it
because honestly I'm more interested
it's a short conversation a fusion
fusion can solve a lot of stuff and I
hope we make it work you know we I would
ask everyone in the audience to lobby
the world's governments to increase
funding for fusion not decrease it which
is the trend oh that's great yeah well I
do have I want to know more about how
tunes but I first before I forget
see I love science
but I also critique it and one of my
issues with science is how it filters
down into society for instance the idea
that as you stated Galileo introduced
this idea that we should be able to
measure everything and make everything
miserable yeah to me in society adopting
this idea it's not always so good for
one thing it turns out to put value on
things you can count or in fact that's
what it means to make something count is
if you can count it and then we have
this whole thing with poles which you
know is a way of counting that in my
mind isn't even scientific all right so
we don't disagree on poles non-being oh
it's good so have you noticed this this
is the thing that makes me think they're
not scientific I I have noticed in the
same way I noticed your socks because I
always noticed the odd detail is that in
almost every poll I read only two
percent don't know it doesn't matter
what the question is just two percent
don't even in things where you would
think it would be impossible not to know
like I read a poll that asked of men
have you ever had sex with a woman
you seriously disliked
is that to me that question well it's
interesting because I mean just what
would your guess be on the percentage
would said yes
so to to avoid this question I have
heard the statistic that you can query
the American population on any singular
question and no matter how ridiculous
the question may be and 20% will answer
positive so you know have you your do
you believe in alien abduction 20% yeah
yes yeah
and question is right so what I want to
know whether man if you say have you you
know they don't even listen to the rest
of the question have you ever had sex
yes but what was interesting to me was
you know it turns out that fifty five
percent said yes which was encouraging I
thought that's just like the less than
two-thirds no 58 percent said yes forty
percent two percent not know didn't know
two percent didn't know whether they'd
had sex with a woman they seriously
disliked so polls to me and I'm happy to
hear to you or something
suspect yeah it is I think where we're
learning to deal with statistics better
but these polls don't seem like they're
terribly you know the the problem the
unscientific part of the poll to me is
the way you answer the question in the
way you phrase it and there's too much
semantics in the question o2 to give you
a really great sign of the answer
absolutely
I once because I'm sure some of those
men were like that I had sex with a
woman that was the sex bad or was the
woman bad right so it would have been a
certain number who were just like I did
I dislike the six that I had with this
woman rather than that dislike you think
I think they gave it not enough
authority to make sure they understood
the quick
Oh what about this one this one killed
me this was asked if marry jewish women
is to your husband jewish two percent
didn't know i mean that's why i always
leave a light on but so is the twenty
minutes up right you know this is why a
few conveniens it's it's it's wonderful
but no no hit me again i like it
so tell me about how tunes cuz i'm this
i think is fantastic okay so I work with
a wonderful illustrator called Nick
regatta who in his day job is drawing
comics for DC and Marvel superheroes and
women with cats tails and double D
breasts and that type of stuff that's
contempt that's where comics ended up
right but we are very interested in how
do you illustrate in an adventurous way
science and engineering for sort of
eight to ten year olds and so we should
think of ridiculous adventure stories
and he illustrates those adventure
stories and hopefully they motivate kids
to not have a fear of the physical world
like in some respects we're just trying
to encourage that you can tinker with
the world you can break your toys the
world is understandable don't have any
fear of it just play with it an
experiment with it oh that's so much
better than making science accessible to
children yeah no that's not good I think
with this we believe science education
is in a horrible place I know I'm making
a movie that is because I think as I
have I'm sure indicated by now that's my
interest in science is because I think
the big ideas from science filtered down
to society and then are appropriated for
good or for ill so my question you do
you think science is when you're losing
and what I mean do you think what I mean
specifically is do you think rational
thought ah is winning or losing I'm
actually I'm right I'm
I'm looking I'm trying to find
desperately things to cling to that are
positive about the future and I actually
think that science is way you know I
feel hosts with my own petard because I
have been critiquing rationalism not
rationality about rationalism for a
while and now that the United States is
having this what I call the revolt
against Reason which is basically what's
going on
I mean people honor us with facts we
don't want to you know let us just make
up whatever we want and let us just go
solely on the power of our emotional
response to things and the country and
these people what bothers me is their
inability to understand when they're
even contradicting themselves and I'm
looking for an example of that I found
that was so amazing which was a personal
ad in an Israeli newspaper and it said
what's oh here it is it said I am a
sensitive Jewish man whom you can open
your heart to share your innermost
thoughts and deepest secrets confide in
me I'll understand your insecurities no
fatties please
and but you know you listen to it
Tea Partiers whatever and the
contradictions are just phenomenal and
the other thing that goes along with
this to me and this you know I'm curious
about whether or not science played a
role at all in this because you know
Danny and I have talked about this
because I critique rational choice that
discipline of economics that uses
mathematical models to predict the way
rational agents will behave and anything
that doesn't fit the model sort of gets
thrown out like the way people actually
behave so you're confusing again
economics with science well when I
brought this up with Danny Danny said
but you know science uses mathematical
models because they are good metaphors
Danny understands that they're not
actual reality but I think the
distinction between what is something I
now call correspondence reality where
it's kind of like reality but not really
like reality and then it happens you
know back up to hit you in the face like
I read in the National Inquirer story
about an Australian lion tamer who'd
been mauled by his lion and the
scientist sentence that I thought was
really interesting and troublesome was
mr. Russell who learned lion taming
through a correspondence course but I
think a lot of that is going on right
now and of course in the Bush White
House you know they they made fun of the
fact based reality so it does worry me
I'm with you on i completely agree and
so at some larger level where it's easy
to feel like we're losing but all of
those people and this is what gives me
hope is is that all of those people when
they're making purchasing decisions or
decisions about their health yeah so you
know my wife has a family who were very
religious her cousins and these ananka
'ls and and probably our tea party ish I
don't know if I should have said this
because they were recording it
I know what recording it and so in this
in many ways these are people that you
know don't believe in evolution and and
climate change and these things and and
that's fine they're actually actually
some of the best they have some of the
best sense of family of anyone I've ever
met and that's really lovely but at the
same time they're they have those
opinions you know they really listen to
the latest public health research so
they're making the best decisions about
where to get their water from or as this
shampoo gonna be more toxic or less
toxic than that and I think this is
prevalent in in you know actually we we
I have an 18 month old son and my wife
who is not a scientist looks for the
latest science on you know sources of
lead sources and this is this is science
filtering down and I think people are
absorbed a li basis I think people were
touching a lot more of these things
whether the quality of the science that
goes in all this studies is good or not
is another question but I think we are
listening with hope that what the way I
think science is winning because of this
is because we are slowly understanding
that it is our best hope at finding the
right answer well first of all these
same people are rebelling against health
care that would benefit them so I'm not
sure it's always true and secondly it
makes me nervous to think in terms of
winning and losing because it sets up
what I think of as a post economy that
the more we go with that either-or logic
and set things I know well that's my
other issue with science but I think
let's see I'm looking to negotiate the
tension between us not to win or lose
and that's I wish science would make
more of that accommodation I think so
I'm really interested in it obviously it
frustrates you how do we improve it
because I mean I actually think
scientists are responsible for doing an
awful job of communicating what they do
and their science and I think it's a
very open question how do we how do we
do it better so you sound like the most
qualified or at least most angry person
I've ever met
most angry at their community why I mean
actually most people are dispassionate I
mean we can pulp the audience who here
who here thinks science communication is
good or bad I'm just asking how do we
improve okay
2% of the audience thinks you're angry
[Laughter]
so well I don't feel as if I'm angry I
feel as if I honestly care passionately
about let me rephrase my question
because I introduced a wood that was it
was hot anger but so how do we do it
better because it is honestly what's
your vision first my vision oh wow
that's a big question my vision is that
for instance it upsets me I listen to
Richard Dawkins the other day on NPR and
one of the callers who was said that he
had been brought up Catholic and he had
this idea blah blah blah and Richard
Dawkins started to give a very good
answer and then he said but if you'd
been brought up in a different religion
you'd have a different set of beliefs so
doesn't that make you feel kind of
stupid and that's it was that right why
go there because we're human but it
isn't like you know a momentary slip
that there are and I guess we need them
I mean my ideas as long as we have so
many rabid people and true believers on
this end of the spectrum we should have
some on that end of the spectrum and the
rest of us you know can sort of
negotiate that middle part but I do feel
that the arrogance with which some
scientists present themselves and the
idea that irrational
you know to me the wonderful thing about
science and then one of the reasons I
got so fascinated by it was when I read
about girdle's incompleteness theorem
and it was like oh my god finally a
universe that resembles something I know
something confusing yeah
something absurd I mean to me it was
like going from a clockwork universe
which is boring to me to a banana peel
universe which you never know when
you're going to show and that to me I
would like to see science presenting
itself but I know it's very difficult to
do when you're under attack but
presenting itself as what it really is
willing to change its mind so I
completely agree I mean that's why I
think I have the the view in my head
that in inevitably science doesn't win
or lose but it it increases in its value
because it is the self modifying base of
knowledge that's how I actually
understand and my concern and my passion
also comes from the fact that I don't
know how you have a secular democracy if
you don't have science as a storyteller
so to me if you're making science the
villain that wasn't very funny it made
me think really hard but I think I agree
but you know why that's so good here
because I wrote down something someone
said about yeah oh god no no no no this
is about the world in the future no no
no this is so good it's just somebody
said about units or maybe you said that
so much of innovation comes from
connecting across things where other
people don't make connections and it
goes there are direct but invisible
threads that run from the frivolous to
the profound so that's where comedy and
science are completely alike
I agree this is actually been a great
day I had very few dates when I was
young there were this challenging well I
think does that mean I think we've got
15 seconds so I can tell a filthy
Limerick thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you